if you've got it grandma you know she
loves to ask questions so when are you
getting married having kids when you're
gonna go to graduate school and how much
- it can be hard to keep your cool are
you getting married when are you getting
married grandma or are you afraid your
next husband is gonna try to escape like
your last one now it's easy to say what
grandma wants to hear with grenades
grenades is the first ever selective
hearing aid it filters out anything that
would upset grandma so she only hears
things she approves of what happened to
that boyfriend of yours he's a drunk and
my doctor thinks he gave me chlamydia
but thanks to granny aids here's what
grandma heard he's a doctor
booth I'm voting for whoever will crush
the white supremacist I'm voting
for the white supremacist make this
holiday a happy one with grand aids I
have you to thank gran aids you have
eight wait that means want me to have
AIDS
[Music]
grenades
[Applause]